This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In Greek mythology, the sirens were alluring secretures who sang beautiful and beguiling songs. Sailors, lured by these sirens, found themselves running a ground on rocks and capsizing. It's the origin of the phrase siren song to describe a temptation that conceals danger. According to Greek mythology, the warrior Eulaceus wanted to hear the song of the sirens, but feared he would lose control
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。在希腊神话中，塞壬是迷人的生物，她们唱着优美而诱人的歌。水手们被这些塞壬吸引，最终触礁沉船。“塞壬之歌”这个词正是起源于此，用来形容掩盖危险的诱惑。根据希腊神话，勇士奥德修斯想听塞壬的歌声，但又担心自己会失去理智。
of his faculties and run his ship around. So he had his men bind him to the mast of his own ship. When he heard the song of the sirens, the ropes constrained him from giving into temptation. In modern times, social scientists and lawyers design what are sometimes known as Eulicee Spacts or Eulicee's Contracts. Exactly as in the myth, these are ways you can limit what you yourself can do in the future. If you feel you are likely to make mistakes. If you fear you are at risk for dementia for example, you can sign over power of attorney to a relative to keep yourself
从而导致船只触礁。于是他让手下把自己绑在船桅上。当他听到塞壬的歌声时，绳索束缚着他，使他无法屈服于诱惑。在现代，社会科学家和律师设计了有时被称为“奥德修斯契约”的东西。正如神话中那样，这是一种限制你未来行为的方法。如果你觉得你很可能会犯错。例如，如果你担心自己有患痴呆症的风险，你可以将授权书签署给亲属，以防止自己
from making poor decisions in the years to come. States and nations sometimes pass laws to constrain themselves from overspending future budgets. When you skip buying chips and soda at the grocery store, because you worry you will give into temptation if you keep junk food at home, you are crafting a soft version of a Eulacee's pact with yourself. You are constraining what you will do in the future. Today, in the next installment of our U2.0 series, we will explore new research into how to become a better designer of your future self. How to craft choices that will make for better tomorrow's, this week on Hidden Brain. In 2003, Washington Mutual Bank introduced a new ad campaign titled The Power of Yes.
在未来做出糟糕的决定。国家和政府有时会通过法律来约束自己，防止未来预算超支。当你因为担心如果家里有垃圾食品就会屈服于诱惑，而不在杂货店购买薯片和汽水时，你其实是在为自己制定一个“奥德修斯契约”的简化版。你正在约束自己未来的行为。今天，在我们“U2.0”系列的下一期节目中，我们将探索关于如何成为更好的未来自我设计师的新研究。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨如何做出选择，从而创造更美好的明天。2003年，华盛顿互惠银行推出了一项名为“是的权力”的新广告活动。
The uncertainty of getting a home loan made Paul irritable. Then he went to Washington, Mutual. Thanks to their flexible lending rules, Paul got a quick approval. Now he's always in a great mood. The power of yes was more than just an advertising slogan. It was an operating principle for the bank, which began saying yes and giving loans to most everyone who applied. Former employees at WAMU, as the bank was known, have said that higher-up started pushing agents
获得住房贷款的不确定性让保罗感到烦躁。然后他去了华盛顿互惠银行。多亏了他们灵活的贷款规则，保罗很快就获得了批准。现在他总是心情很好。“是的权力”不仅仅是一个广告口号。它是该银行的经营原则，银行开始对几乎所有申请贷款的人说“是”，并提供贷款。华盛顿互惠银行（WAMU）的前员工表示，高层开始向代理人施压，
to grant loans regardless of customers' income or assets. One would be borrower, told the bank he was making six figures as a mariachi singer. WAMU's loan officer could not verify the singer's income, so he had the singer photographed while dressed in his Mariathe outfit. The picture became part of the customer's application, and the bank gave his loan a thumbs up.
要求他们无论客户的收入或资产如何，都要发放贷款。一位借款人告诉银行，他作为一名墨西哥流浪乐队歌手，年收入六位数。华盛顿互惠银行的贷款专员无法核实这位歌手的收入，于是他让这位歌手穿着他的演出服拍了张照片。这张照片成了客户申请材料的一部分，银行也批准了他的贷款。
So these loan officers, they frequently knew that they were making mortgages to people who had no chance of paying them back at all. That's Kirsten Grind, Wall Street Journal reporter and author of the book The Lost Bank. It is not an exaggeration when I say that literally dead people were getting mortgages. A major reality check arrived in 2008 when Borowas started defaulting on their mortgages and housing prices began to crash. Washington Mutual Bank collapsed. It's being called the biggest bank failure in U.S. history.
所以这些贷款专员经常知道，他们发放的抵押贷款对象根本没有偿还能力。这是《华尔街日报》记者、《迷失的银行》一书的作者克里斯汀·格林所说的。我说“死人实际上也在获得抵押贷款”并不夸张。2008年，当借款人开始拖欠抵押贷款，房价开始崩盘时，现实给了银行沉重的一击。华盛顿互惠银行倒闭了。这被称为美国历史上最大的银行倒闭案。
Seattle-based savings and loan Washington Mutual had suffered big losses selling risky mortgages to home buyers. In a Senate hearing, Michigan Senator Carl Levin criticized the bank's leadership. Because volume and speed were king, loan quality fell by the wayside, and WAMU churned out more and more loans that were high risk and poor quality. The ill-considered loans approved by Washington Mutual and other banks played a big role in the financial crisis that rocked the global economy and contributed to what has been called the Great Recession. Looking back at this chapter in recent history, we might ask what prompted so many people to act
总部位于西雅图的储蓄贷款机构华盛顿互惠银行因向购房者出售高风险抵押贷款而遭受了巨大损失。在参议院听证会上，密歇根州参议员卡尔·莱文批评了该银行的领导层。因为业务量和速度是王道，贷款质量被抛在了脑后，华盛顿互惠银行不断地发放越来越多高风险、低质量的贷款。华盛顿互惠银行和其他银行批准的这些考虑不周的贷款，在动摇全球经济的金融危机中发挥了巨大作用，并促成了所谓的“大衰退”。回顾这段近现代史，我们可能会问，是什么促使这么多人采取
in such a short-sighted way. Was it stupidity? Greed? At UCLA, psychologists had Herschfield agrees that those were factors. But he says there was also a psychological factor at play, a psychological factor that affects all of us all the time. There's a problem on so many different levels. Washington Mutual is answering to shareholders and to Wall Street to some degree. And then, you know, that means that employees are answering to executives who are saying, you know, push out more and more loans. We need to have more and more revenue. Part of the problem
如此短视的行为。是愚蠢吗？贪婪吗？加州大学洛杉矶分校的心理学家哈尔·赫什菲尔德同意这些都是因素。但他表示，还有一个心理因素在起作用，一个时刻影响着我们所有人的心理因素。这在很多不同层面上都是个问题。华盛顿互惠银行在某种程度上要对股东和华尔街负责。然后，你知道，这意味着员工要对高管负责，而高管们说，你知道，发放更多的贷款。我们需要有越来越多的收入。问题的一部分
here was almost a failure to see the end of this, right? There's just no way that it could be sustainable to constantly be making these massive loans to people who had no means to pay for them. And I think there is this pervasive sense in this example, and it's an extreme one, that these consequences are never going to come. Can you talk a moment about how even though this might be an outlier, the larger principle that play here, which is that we are under counting, under valuing what's going to happen in the future, in order to get what we want in the present, this is really something of
在于几乎无法预见结局，对吧？不断向那些根本没有偿还能力的人发放巨额贷款，这在任何情况下都不可能是可持续的。我认为在这个例子中有一种普遍的感觉，这是一个极端的例子，即这些后果永远不会到来。你能谈谈为什么尽管这可能是一个特例，但这里起作用的更大原则是，为了得到我们现在想要的东西，我们正在低估未来会发生什么，这实际上是
a pervasive problem across all of human nature. Yeah, that's right. Economists and psychologists call this temporal discounting, which is a fancy term to basically say that we discount the value of future rewards relative to present ones. So if I have an option for something right now, and I can get it, but I may end up suffering later on, I'm maybe oriented to just say, yeah, I'll go for it. You can see this when it comes to, you know, overspending versus saving or exercising versus sitting on the couch and overeating versus eating, you know, a healthier, more modest portion, these sorts of things.
贯穿整个人性的一种普遍问题。是的，没错。经济学家和心理学家称之为“时间贴现”，这是一个花哨的术语，基本上是说我们相对于现在的奖励，会打折未来奖励的价值。所以，如果我现在有一个选择，我可以得到它，但我以后可能会受苦，我可能倾向于说，好吧，我选它。当涉及到，你知道，过度消费与储蓄，或者锻炼与坐在沙发上暴饮暴食，或者吃更健康、更适度的份量时，你就能看到这一点，诸如此类。
And that being pervasive problems. You see that many of our problems flow from a disjunction between our present cells and our future cells. And you experienced one version of this when you signed up for a very difficult, neural anatomy class during grad school. Tell me the story of what happened, how? Sure. So I was at this period of time where I had taken my required courses and I still had some
这些都是普遍存在的问题。你会发现我们的许多问题源于我们现在的自我和未来的自我之间的脱节。你在研究生院选修一门非常困难的神经解剖学课程时，就经历过这种情况。讲讲发生了什么，怎么回事？当然。当时我修完了必修课，还有一些
space in my schedule. I could take whatever I wanted and I said, you know what'd be really interesting is to take this neuro anatomy class at the med school. And I got there and realized quickly, this is definitely far beyond the level that I need to know, but I still thought, I'll sit in in it, but let me just make sure that I take this
时间表上的空档。我可以选任何我想选的课，我说，你知道什么会很有趣吗？去医学院修这门神经解剖学课。我到了那里，很快意识到，这绝对远远超出了我需要掌握的水平，但我还是想，我会旁听，但我得确保我选这门课是
as a pass fail class. make sure that I, you know, take this as a pass-fail class. All that Hal had to do was file a request with the registrar. Instead of getting a letter grade, he would only aim for a passing grade. He told himself he'd file the request soon, but each day he found he was busy and would put off the chore to the following day. I have to say I kept sort of pushing it off and then the end of the quarter came and there was going to be this really intense final exam and I said, okay, well I'm taking the class pass fail.
以“及格/不及格”的方式。确保我，你知道，以“及格/不及格”的方式选修这门课。哈尔所要做的就是向教务处提交一份申请。他将不再追求字母评分，而只追求及格。他告诉自己很快就会提交申请，但每天他都发现自己很忙，就把这件事推迟到第二天。我不得不说，我一直把它推迟，然后学期末到了，有一场非常紧张的期末考试，我说，好吧，我选的是“及格/不及格”。
I will study for it because I want to pass but I'm not going to study for it to such degree that I will necessarily get an A. I want it to be mindful of my time. So I study, study, study, I take the exam and I have this distinct memory where it's the day that I've taken the exam. I think we might have gone out to dinner that night, I go to bed, I wake up in the middle of the night and I have this sudden question hanging over me, which is, oh my gosh, did I remember to switch the past mail? And I check the next morning, and sure enough, I am still signed up for a letter grade.
我会为它学习，因为我想及格，但我不会为了拿A而过度学习。我想合理利用我的时间。所以我学习、学习、再学习，我参加了考试，我有一个清晰的记忆，就是我参加考试的那天。我想那天晚上我们可能出去吃了晚饭，我上床睡觉，半夜醒来，我突然有一个问题悬在心头，那就是，天哪，我记得把评分方式改成“及格/不及格”了吗？第二天早上我查了一下，果然，我还是注册的字母评分。
Well, I didn't even know the grade I got, but I emailed the professor and I said, please, I meant to do this. I meant to make a past fail. And he said, there's nothing I can do but the registrar isn't controlled here. And I'll, I'll, Shankar, I'll never forget the registrar's name because it was the most perfect name
好吧，我甚至不知道我得了什么分数，但我给教授发了邮件，我说，拜托，我本来打算这么做的。我本来打算改成“及格/不及格”。他说，我无能为力，教务处控制着这里。而且，尚卡尔，我永远不会忘记教务处负责人的名字，因为那是一个最完美的名字。
is Roger printup, which, you know, for someone who deals with paperwork all day. And I, you know, send this desperate plea to him and to his credit, he writes back and says, this is a very difficult case, but we have a hard and fast rule of not changing the letter grade versus pass fail status after the deadline. How's Crayp Through, but got a terrible grade?
是罗杰·普林塔普（Roger Printup），你知道，对于一个整天处理文书工作的人来说。我，你知道，向他发出了绝望的请求，值得称赞的是，他回信说，这是一个非常困难的案例，但我们有严格的规定，截止日期后不能更改字母评分与“及格/不及格”的状态。哈尔搞砸了，但得到了一个糟糕的分数？
His procrastination when it came to filing the request with the registrar had cost him dearly. the procrastination when it came to filing the request with the registrar had cost him dearly. Looking back, how things this example illustrates one way in which we fail to do well by our future selves. We imagine our future selves will be different from our current selves in some convenient way. How I told myself, I'm busy, so I'll put off this chore until tomorrow.
他在向教务处提交申请方面的拖延让他付出了沉重的代价。他在向教务处提交申请方面的拖延让他付出了沉重的代价。回顾过去，哈尔认为这个例子说明了我们未能善待未来自我的一种方式。我们想象未来的自己会以某种方便的方式与现在的自己不同。哈尔告诉自己，我很忙，所以我把这个琐事推迟到明天。
Of course, when the next day rolled around, Hal was just as busy. Another way we do a disservice to our future selves is that we prioritize the concerns of the present and disregard the consequences. Hal cites another example from his own life. This was about 12 years ago or so. My wife and I were living apart.
当然，当第二天到来时，哈尔依然很忙。我们亏待未来自我的另一种方式是，我们优先考虑当前的担忧，而无视后果。哈尔引用了他自己生活中的另一个例子。那大约是12年前左右。我和妻子分居两地。
We knew it was going to be about two years. She was in Chicago, I was in New York. And the way that we worked things out was that, you know, during the week we were in our separate jobs and cities and then we would try our very best to see each other on weekends. But what that meant was I was trying to work as efficiently and smartly as I could during the week. So one of the things that I tried to save time on was cooking, or rather not cooking. Now, where I lived in the city, there were lots of these little sort of convenience stores,
我们知道大约需要两年时间。她在芝加哥，我在纽约。我们解决问题的方式是，你知道，周一到周五我们在各自的城市工作，然后我们尽量在周末见面。但这意味着我试图在工作日尽可能高效、聪明地工作。所以我试图节省时间的一件事是做饭，或者说是不做饭。现在，在我住的城市里，有很多这种小型的便利店，
which also had sort of hot prepared food in the back of the store. And there was one right across my office, and I would go in there and sort of load up, and it was, you know, by way, and I sort of said, ah, I'm just going to get as much as I can to. And I'm looking back, I can't say it was the healthiest stuff. And this was my routine for a while. And then I went in for my annual physical, and I was in my early 30s at the time,
店后面也有那种热的预制食品。我办公室对面就有一家，我会进去买很多，你知道，顺便说一句，我当时想，啊，我只要能买多少就买多少。回顾过去，我不能说那是多健康的东西。这曾是我一段时间的日常。然后我去做了年度体检，当时我才30出头，
I went in for my annual physical. And my doctor said, you know, I looked at your numbers and I think it's time we put you on statins for your very high cholesterol. And I said, wait, what's? But on each given day when you were busy, it did make sense in some ways to basically say
我去做了年度体检。我的医生说，你知道，我看了你的数据，我认为是时候让你服用他汀类药物来治疗你的高胆固醇了。我说，等等，什么？但在你忙碌的每一天里，在某种程度上，说“我很忙，我很饿，我只是去买点吃的，不去想它”确实是有道理的。当然，你在那一刻没有做的是问自己，六个月后当我在医生办公室时会发生什么。是的，在某种程度上，就好像我把每一个现在的一天与随后的日子分离开来。今天我可以这样做。回顾过去，就好像我没有看到所有那些不同的餐点和所有那些不同的日子是如何加起来，创造了一个更具问题的整体。
I'm busy, I'm hungry, I'm just going to pick up some food and not going to think about it. And of course, what you're not doing in that moment is asking what's going to happen six months from now when I'm in the doctor's office. Yeah, in a way, it was as if I was separating out each present day from the days that followed. Today I can do this. Looking back, it was almost as if I didn't see how all those different meals and all those different days could add up to create a much more problematic hole.
（注：此段与20段内容重叠，已合并处理）
A third way in which we do a disservice to our future selves is through what you call a failure of imagination. We find it hard to imagine that our future selves will want different things than we want. You experienced this after you moved from New York to Los Angeles and went house hunting with your wife. Tell me the story of what happened. Yeah, sure.
我们亏待未来自我的第三种方式是通过你所说的“想象力的失败”。我们发现很难想象未来的自己会想要与现在不同的东西。你在从纽约搬到洛杉矶并与妻子一起找房子后就经历了这一点。讲讲发生了什么。是的，当然。
So, you know, we had been living in New York at the time and we were in a small New York apartment and we got out to Los Angeles and we were looking for a place to live. And when we looked for what mattered to us, we said we wanted to be walkable and I want to be near coffee shops and I want to be, you know, near some bars. I was essentially trying to recreate the exact experience we had in New York out in Los Angeles. And we were really fortunate to find something. And it was in, you know, a neighborhood that seemed fun to us. The house seemed big.
所以，你知道，我们当时住在纽约，住在一个狭小的纽约公寓里，我们到了洛杉矶，正在找住的地方。当我们寻找对我们重要的事情时，我们说我们想要步行可达，我想要靠近咖啡店，我想要，你知道，靠近一些酒吧。我本质上是想在洛杉矶重现我们在纽约的完全相同的体验。我们真的很幸运找到了一个地方。它位于，你知道，一个我们觉得有趣的社区。房子看起来很大。
In some ways, I think it was big compared to our small New York apartment. And about a year later, my wife became pregnant with our first kid. And quickly, those things that seem to be really important, the distance to bars and coffee shops, weren't quite as relevant. Yeah. And in some ways, the transition to parenthood is an extraordinary transition. And perhaps it's especially hard for us to imagine when we're single and childless, what it's like to be married with children, that is a big transition.
在某些方面，我认为它与我们狭小的纽约公寓相比很大。大约一年后，我妻子怀上了我们的第一个孩子。很快，那些看起来非常重要的事情，比如到酒吧和咖啡店的距离，就不那么重要了。是的。在某些方面，向为人父母的转变是一个非凡的转变。当我们单身且没有孩子时，也许很难想象结婚并有了孩子是什么样子，那是一个巨大的转变。
But the same phenomenon plays out in lots of other ways, which is it's very hard sometimes to imagine that 10 years from now, 20 years from now, we will want different things. This research by Dan Gilbert and Tim Wilson and Jordy Quitebach that basically shows that at every life stage, people believe that they are now baked, that they're not going to change very much in the future. And of course, they do change.
但同样的现象在许多其他方面也在上演，即有时很难想象10年后、20年后，我们会想要不同的东西。丹·吉尔伯特、蒂姆·威尔逊和乔迪·奎特巴赫的这项研究基本上表明，在人生的每个阶段，人们都认为他们现在已经定型了，未来不会有太大的改变。当然，他们确实会改变。
Yeah, it's one of my favorite sort of psychological effects they, you know, they call it the end of history illusion. And it's essentially suggesting that we recognize that we've changed from the past to the present. And although we assume that we will change a little bit from now to the future, we think that as they say the rate of progress somehow will slow down, that we are who we are now. And I find this to be a really interesting mistake of sorts, because when making decisions, thinking about, say, you know, moving and, you know, being childless and married to now having kids, we mistakenly think that our present-day circumstances may end up being relatively similar and
是的，这是我最喜欢的心理效应之一，他们，你知道，称之为“历史终结错觉”。它本质上是暗示我们承认我们从过去到现在的变化。虽然我们假设从现在到未来我们会有一点变化，但我们认为，正如他们所说，进步的速度会以某种方式放缓，我们就是现在的我们。我发现这是一个非常有趣的错误，因为在做决定时，考虑到，比如，你知道，搬家，你知道，从没有孩子和结婚到现在有了孩子，我们错误地认为我们当下的环境可能会在从现在到时间尽头保持相对相似和
stable from now until the end of time, and that's just not true. From Greek mythology to modern-day Greek tragedies like Washington Mutual, human beings struggle every day to make good choices for their future selves. When we make bad decisions, we often assume that we are being shot-sided or giving in too easily to temptations. When we come back, Hal discovers a much more interesting reason why many of us fail to do right by our future selves and how we can do better. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
稳定，但这根本不是真的。从希腊神话到像华盛顿互惠银行这样的现代希腊悲剧，人类每天都在努力为未来的自己做出正确的选择。当我们做出错误的决定时，我们通常认为自己是短视的，或者太容易屈服于诱惑。回来后，哈尔会发现一个更有趣的原因，解释为什么我们许多人未能善待未来的自己，以及我们如何才能做得更好。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Hal Hirschfield is a psychologist at UCLA. He studies our relationship to our future selves, the people we are going to become. Hal, early in your career, you conducted research involving FMRI machines to scan the brains of volunteers. Tell me how that experiment was set up and what it revealed. So what we were doing in this particular study was having people make judgments as they thought about themselves now or themselves in the future,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。哈尔·赫什菲尔德是加州大学洛杉矶分校的心理学家。他研究我们与未来自我的关系，即我们将要成为的人。哈尔，在你职业生涯的早期，你进行了涉及功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）机器的研究，以扫描志愿者的大脑。告诉我那个实验是如何设置的，以及它揭示了什么。所以我们在那个特定的研究中所做的是让人们在思考现在的自己或未来的自己时做出判断，
or another person now or another person in the future. And what we found was that the brain activity that arose when people thought about their future selves on average looked more similar to the activity that arose when people thought about others. to the activity that arose when people thought about others. It's almost as if on a brain level, the future self looked like another person. So that's interesting because of course at an intuitive level all of us imagine that the people were going to be in 30 years, we're still going to say I'm still going to be shunker and you're still going to be how, but you're still going to be how. But you're saying in the brain, they seem so distant
或者思考现在的另一个人或未来的另一个人。我们发现，当人们思考未来的自己时，大脑活动平均看起来与人们思考他人时产生的活动更为相似。就好像在大脑层面上，未来的自我看起来像另一个人。这很有趣，因为当然在直觉层面上，我们所有人都想象我们30年后会成为的人，我仍然会是尚卡尔，你仍然会是哈尔，但你说在大脑中，他们看起来如此遥远
and so far away from us that they seem like literally like different people. Yeah, I think on the surface, if you were to ask people, will you still be you and are you still the same you as you were when you were eight or nine? I think on the surface, yeah, yeah, I'm still how. I still have my same first name. I'm still have some of the same friends and so on. But then you start really getting down
离我们如此之远，以至于他们看起来简直就像不同的人。是的，我认为从表面上看，如果你问人们，你还会是你吗？你还是你8岁或9岁时的那个你吗？我想从表面上看，是的，我仍然是哈尔。我仍然有同样的名字。我仍然有一些同样的朋友等等。但当你真正深入到
to a deeper level and I'm not so sure that that answer is still true. You know, I, I've moved, you know, your last name might change, your hair color might change, your preferences, your likes, your dislikes, these things may change as well. And so on some level, it may be understandable that our future selves look almost as if they are other people. So other lines of research have confirmed this finding. Tell me about the study conducted by Emily Prownan and Liraus. So Emily Prownan and Liraus did this really interesting study where they went to college students and they had them write about a meal that they were currently eating.
更深层次时，我不确定那个答案是否仍然正确。你知道，我搬家了，你的姓氏可能会改变，你的发色可能会改变，你的偏好、你的喜好、你的厌恶，这些事情也可能会改变。因此，在某种程度上，我们的未来自我看起来几乎像是其他人，这是可以理解的。所以其他研究也证实了这一发现。告诉我艾米丽·普罗南和李·罗斯进行的研究。所以艾米丽·普罗南和李·罗斯做了这个非常有趣的研究，他们去找大学生，让他们写下他们目前正在吃的一顿饭。
And when they did so, they were likely to sort of describe it as the meal was laid out in front of them. They were likely to use the first person perspective. Now, they had a different group of college students right about a meal that they would eat in the very distant future, which to college students is like somewhere over the age of 40, I believe. And this group of students was considerably more likely to adopt the third person perspective that is they would see their future self as if it was another person in the scene. It was almost as if they were using an observer's perspective.
当他们这样做时，他们很可能会描述这顿饭摆在他们面前的样子。他们很可能会使用第一人称视角。现在，他们让另一组大学生写下他们在遥远的未来会吃的一顿饭，对于大学生来说，这大约是在40岁以后，我相信。这组学生更有可能采用第三人称视角，也就是说，他们会把未来的自己看作是场景中的另一个人。就好像他们在使用观察者的视角。
So it's almost as if when people act in short-sighted ways, when they fail to plan ahead, we conclude they are poor planners or lack self-control, but your research and this work by Emily and by Lee almost seems to be hinting at a different conclusion. Yeah, I think if we start to think about how we relate to our future selves as if they're other people, then it can start to shed some light
所以就好像当人们以短视的方式行事，当他们未能提前计划时，我们得出结论他们是糟糕的规划者或缺乏自制力，但你的研究和艾米丽以及李的这项工作似乎在暗示一个不同的结论。是的，我认为如果我们开始思考我们如何与未来的自我建立联系，就好像他们是其他人一样，那么它就可以开始阐明
while we sometimes act in these ways that may seem short-sighted. I mean, think about it this way. How do we treat strangers in our lives, right? If a stranger, or even if a coworker who I barely know, if they came up to me and asked me for help, I don't know, moving this weekend, I'd probably come up with a lot of reasons
为什么我们有时会以这些看起来短视的方式行事。我的意思是，换个角度想。我们如何对待生活中的陌生人，对吧？如果一个陌生人，甚至是一个我几乎不认识的同事，如果他们走过来向我寻求帮助，我不知道，这个周末搬家，我可能会想出很多理由
why I wouldn't be able to help them. And it's not because I'm selfish, but I do consider my own self-interest. It doesn't really make sense for me to do that. Well, if my future self is like that coworker, I don't know, or like that complete stranger on the street, in a way, it's almost rational to prioritize today over tomorrow. It's like the consequences of my actions aren't really going to happen to me.
为什么我无法帮助他们。这并不是因为我自私，但我确实考虑了我自己的利益。那样做对我来说真的没有意义。好吧，如果我未来的自己就像那个同事，我不知道，或者像街上的那个完全陌生的人，在某种程度上，优先考虑今天而不是明天几乎是理性的。就好像我行为的后果并不会真正发生在我身上。
They're going to happen to some other guy, some guy barely know. So in other words, why act in an ethical way? Why follow the law when the punishment for any infractions will be endured by somebody else? Why pass up on the extra slice of chocolate when the pounds will show up on somebody else's waistline? Why say for retirement instead of spending it now? You're basically giving away money to a stranger.
它们会发生在另一个家伙身上，一个我几乎不认识的家伙。所以换句话说，为什么要以道德的方式行事？当任何违规行为的惩罚都将由别人承担时，为什么要遵守法律？当磅数会出现在别人的腰围上时，为什么要放弃那块额外的巧克力？为什么要为退休储蓄而不是现在就花掉它？你基本上是在把钱送给一个陌生人。
Exactly. And I mean to some extent, this is an analogy, right? We don't turn into literally another person when we become our future selves, but it's an analogy that's really powerful. Because as you said, these decisions I'm making right now will have consequences, but it's easy to write off those consequences if they're going to occur to somebody I barely am connected to. So your research has found that the more our perception of our future cells resembles our perception of strangers, the more likely we are to engage in what you have called temporal discounting, prioritizing the
完全正确。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这是一个类比，对吧？当我们成为未来的自己时，我们并没有真正变成另一个人，但这是一个非常强大的类比。因为正如你所说，我现在做出的这些决定会产生后果，但如果这些后果发生在与我几乎没有联系的人身上，就很容易忽略它们。所以你的研究发现，我们对未来自我的感知越像我们对陌生人的感知，我们就越有可能参与你所说的“时间贴现”，优先考虑
present over the future. Talk about that research, yeah. Sure. I think it's important to recognize that we're not always selfish. We're not always self-interested, right? If one of my best friends asked me for help this weekend, or if my kid did, or my spouse, or my closest family members, I probably would figure out how to drop the things I was going to do to help them. And the same can be said for our future selves. If we feel as if they are strangers, if we feel as if we are not particularly connected to them on an emotional level, then we will probably be more likely to engage in these sort of
现在而不是未来。谈谈那个研究，是的。当然。我认为重要的是要认识到我们并不总是自私的。我们并不总是自私自利的，对吧？如果我最好的朋友之一这个周末向我寻求帮助，或者我的孩子，或者我的配偶，或者我最亲近的家人，我可能会想办法放下我要做的事情去帮助他们。对于我们未来的自我也是如此。如果我们觉得他们是陌生人，如果我们觉得我们在情感层面上与他们没有特别的联系，那么我们可能就更有可能参与这些
temporal discounting-like behaviors. So, what I find really interesting about what you said, Hal, is that it suggests that if we could build a warmer and closer relationship with our future selves, if we come to think of our future selves the way we think about, you know, a beloved child or a spouse or a close friend, we might have a very different relationship to what we're doing in the here and now. That's right. It's really in some ways about injecting a sense of empathy into the relationships that we have with these distant versions of ourselves, right? And, you know, we have found that people who have more of this sense of connection, more of a feeling of overlap with their future selves are more likely to engage in these sorts
类似“时间贴现”的行为。所以，哈尔，我发现你所说的话非常有趣，因为它暗示如果我们能与未来的自己建立一种更温暖、更亲密的关系，如果我们开始像对待，你知道，心爱的孩子、配偶或亲密朋友那样思考未来的自己，我们可能会对我们在此时此地所做的事情有非常不同的关系。没错。在某种程度上，这确实是关于将一种同理心注入到我们与这些遥远的自我版本之间的关系中，对吧？而且，你知道，我们发现那些对未来自我有更多这种联系感、更多重叠感的人，更有可能参与这些
of behaviors that will benefit them over time, but both now and in the future. One of the really interesting and practical ways that you have found that we can build a warmer, closer relationship with our future self has to do with photography. What is the idea, how? So early on, my collaborators and I were trying to figure out, how do we get people to feel more of a sense of connection to their own future selves? It's not an easy thing to do. It's almost like saying, how can I get you
随着时间的推移，无论是在现在还是在未来，都会使他们受益的行为。你发现我们可以与未来自我建立更温暖、更亲密关系的真正有趣且实用的方法之一与摄影有关。这个想法是什么，哈尔？所以早些时候，我和我的合作者试图弄清楚，我们如何让人们对他们自己的未来自我产生更多的联系感？这不是一件容易的事。这几乎就像是说，我怎么能让你
to feel more of a sense of connection to someone you don't really know? Here's one thing we do know. If I can make some sort of target person, more vivid and more emotional, say the recipient of charity, well then you're gonna be more likely to make a donation, right? And so, you know, we wanted to show people
对一个你并不真正认识的人产生更多的联系感？有一件事我们知道。如果我能让某种目标人物更生动、更情绪化，比如慈善捐赠的接受者，那么你就会更有可能进行捐赠，对吧？所以，你知道，我们想向人们展示
what they might look like in the future. And so, you know, one of our studies, we put people into a virtual reality room, in fact, and they had these goggles on, and they would walk around the room, and they would come face-to-face with a virtual mirror, and then staring back at them in that virtual mirror was either a digitally altered image of their future self, or a digital image of their current self. Now, in that first sort of foray at this, we found that the people who were exposed to these age-progressed images intended to save more for the long run. They said they wanted to save more.
他们未来可能的样子。所以，你知道，我们的一项研究中，我们实际上把人们放进了一个虚拟现实房间，他们戴着这些护目镜，他们会在房间里走动，他们会面对面地看到一面虚拟镜子，然后在那面虚拟镜子中盯着他们看的是他们未来自我的数字修改图像，或者是他们当前自我的数字图像。现在，在第一次尝试中，我们发现那些接触到这些年龄增长图像的人打算为长期储蓄更多。他们说他们想存更多的钱。
So in some ways, making the future self more vivid, more clear, is one way to build a closer relationship with the future self. That's exactly right. Part of what we're trying to do here is really sort of turn up the dial on identifiability and vividness. If I can get you to really vividly think about your future self, and I can get you to identify with that person. Well, now all of a sudden, it's much easier to start saying,
所以在某种程度上，让未来的自我更生动、更清晰，是建立与未来自我更亲密关系的一种方式。完全正确。我们在这里试图做的一部分是真正调高可识别性和生动性。如果我能让你非常生动地思考你未来的自己，并且我能让你认同那个人。好吧，现在突然之间，开始说
you know, the things that I'm doing right now are gonna impact not just some sort of perfectly abstract stranger, but somebody who may share things with common in common with me, somebody who may have some of the same feelings as me, and that can then in turn make it likely that will do things that will benefit them. So you and other researchers have found that viewing age-progressed images can have other
你知道，我现在所做的事情不仅会影响某个完全抽象的陌生人，而且会影响一个可能与我有共同点的人，一个可能拥有与我相同感受的人，这就会使我们更有可能做一些对他们有益的事情。所以你和其他研究人员发现，观看年龄增长的图像还可以有其他
salutary effects as well. The behavioral scientist Tamara Tamara Sims, showed age-progressed images to a group of community college students. What was the result, how? Sure, so Tamara Sims and her collaborators, they did this really interesting study where they worked with community college students. This was over a semester-long course. And every few weeks, the students would be shown an image while they were doing sort of checking surveys and half of them got these digitally altered images.
有益的效果。行为科学家塔玛拉·西姆斯向一群社区大学的学生展示了年龄增长的图像。结果如何，哈尔？当然，所以塔玛拉·西姆斯和她的合作者，他们做了这个非常有趣的研究，他们与社区大学的学生合作。这是一个为期一学期的课程。每隔几周，学生们在做调查时就会被展示一张图像，其中一半人得到了这些数字修改后的图像。
It was just a picture of their current self that sort of digitized. The other half got age-progressed images. And what Tamra and her collaborators found was that by the end of the semester, the students who were shown the age progressed images had a higher motivation to learn about finances. And they also showed higher scores on financial knowledge or what researchers call financial literacy. They sort of understanding the concepts of financial decisions a little bit better. they sort of understand the concepts of financial decisions a little bit better. Hmm. I'm wondering if the same idea can be used to help people exercise more. So for example, if I think of myself as being an older person and perhaps a little more frail, could that
那只是他们当前自我的照片，经过了数字化处理。另一半人得到了年龄增长的图像。塔玛拉和她的合作者发现，到学期结束时，那些看到年龄增长图像的学生对学习财务有更高的动力。他们还在财务知识或研究人员所说的“金融素养”方面表现出更高的分数。他们对财务决策的概念理解得更好一点。嗯。我想知道同样的想法是否可以用来帮助人们多锻炼。例如，如果我把自己想象成一个老年人，也许更虚弱一点，这能
motivate me to do a few more healthy things today so that I can have, you know, so that I can be fitter as I get older. Yeah, I mean, there is some other work. Sarah Raposo and Laura Carsonson have worked in progress where they essentially show that when people are exposed to these age-progressed images, again, they are more likely to have self-reported, exercising. I think part of what's happening here is that you're making salient this future version of yourself who will benefit from the exercise right now, sort of helps people step outside of the current moment.
激励我今天多做一些健康的事情，这样我就可以，你知道，这样我就可以在变老时更健康吗？是的，我的意思是，还有一些其他的工作。莎拉·拉波索和劳拉·卡斯滕森有正在进行的工作，他们基本上表明，当人们接触到这些年龄增长的图像时，他们再次更有可能报告自己进行了锻炼。我认为这里发生的部分原因是，你让这个未来版本的自己变得突出，他会从现在的锻炼中受益，这有助于人们走出当前的时刻。
So far, we've looked at different ways in which you can make your future self more vivid. The more we interact with our future self as an extension of ourselves, the better decisions we can make. Researchers have found another method for increasing our sense of closeness to our future selves, writing letters. Some work has found that if we engage in these sorts of conversations with our future selves it can really enhance the bond that we have with them. So Anne Wilson and Yudashishima for instance, had high school students write a letter to their
到目前为止，我们已经研究了你可以让未来自我更生动的不同方法。我们与未来自我互动的次数越多，将其视为我们自身的延伸，我们就能做出更好的决定。研究人员发现了另一种增加我们与未来自我亲近感的方法，即写信。一些研究发现，如果我们与未来的自己进行这种对话，它确实可以增强我们与他们之间的纽带。例如，安妮·威尔逊和尤达·希希马让高中生给他们的
future selves but then also write a letter back from their future selves. And they found that that exercise, that conversation, really dialed up the sense of connection and, and, and quote unquote, continuity that these students felt with their future selves. I think part of what's happening here is the exercise forces you to really step into the shoes of your future selves and see the world through their eyes feel their feelings. So relative to just writing a letter to their future selves, this sort of back and forth exercise made students feel more
未来自我写一封信，但也让他们的未来自我回信。他们发现那个练习，那种对话，确实增强了这些学生与未来自我之间的联系感，以及所谓的“连续性”。我认为这里发生的部分原因是，这个练习迫使你真正站在未来自我的立场上，通过他们的眼睛看世界，感受他们的感受。所以与仅仅给未来的自己写信相比，这种来回的练习让学生们感觉更
willing to engage in career planning, more willing to delay gratification in order to achieve more academic success and so on, things that would, in theory, put them in a better place in the future. It's one thing to feel a connection with your future self. Hal says it's even better if you can feel a sense of responsibility for your future self. Chris Bryan and I ran this project where we worked with university employees and we gave them different retirement saving appeals. So one group got this message that said, save for retirement, save for your future self.
愿意参与职业规划，更愿意为了取得更大的学业成功而推迟满足感等等，这些事情在理论上会让他们在未来处于更好的位置。感受与未来自我的联系是一回事。哈尔说，如果你能对未来的自己有一种责任感，那就更好了。克里斯·布莱恩和我开展了这个项目，我们与大学员工合作，我们给了他们不同的退休储蓄呼吁。所以一组人收到了这条信息，说：为退休储蓄，为未来的自己储蓄。
It's in your best self interest to do so. The other group got a message that said, you have a sense of responsibility toward your future self, save for retirement. So everybody gets kind of the same message, but the difference here is that one message is framed as a sense of responsibility. You know, the types of feelings
这样做符合你最大的自身利益。另一组人收到了一条信息，说：你对未来的自己有一种责任感，为退休储蓄。所以每个人都得到了同样的信息，但这里的区别在于，一条信息被框定为一种责任感。你知道，那种
that we do have for our kids or our loved ones, our close friends. Now, what types of feelings that we do have for our kids or our loved ones or close friends. Now, what we found is that that responsibility appeal, where the future self is this other person, but another person we have this sense of responsibility toward, that one caused people to actually save more, but in particular, it worked particularly well for people who already said they felt a sense of connection toward their future self. So I think this is a really interesting wrinkle here. If I just get you in a simple message to try to take care of your future self, but you
我们对孩子或亲人、亲密朋友所拥有的那种感觉。现在，我们发现那种责任呼吁，即未来的自己是另一个人，但我们对另一个人有一种责任感，那一个确实促使人们存了更多的钱，但特别地，它对那些已经说他们对未来自我有联系感的人特别有效。所以我认为这是一个非常有趣的转折点。如果我只是通过一条简单的信息让你尝试照顾未来的自己，但你
otherwise don't care about them, that message may fall on deaf ears. It's sort of like asking you to donate to a charity that you have no connection to. But if I can first understand your level of connection and maybe even first dial it up, then that sense of responsibility message will matter. I mean, I don't want to stretch this analogy too far, but in some ways what you're really painting here is a picture of how we form connections with other people. I mean, think about how we make friends in general. You know you get to know someone, and then you see their face, and maybe you write them a letter, and maybe they write you back a letter, and then you do things together, and then
否则并不关心他们，那条信息可能会被置若罔闻。这就像让你向一个你没有任何联系的慈善机构捐款。但如果我能先了解你的联系程度，甚至先调高它，那么那种责任感信息就会很重要。我的意思是，我不想把这个类比延伸得太远，但在某种程度上，你在这里真正描绘的是我们如何与他人建立联系。我的意思是，想想我们通常是如何交朋友的。你知道你认识某人，然后你看到他们的脸，也许你给他们写了一封信，也许他们给你回了一封信，然后你们一起做事情，然后
you have a sense of connection with them, and then maybe eventually a sense of responsibility to them. And all of these things, in some way, stack one on top of the other. And when you get all of those things, that's when you have the very powerful bonds between parent and child, or between romantic partners, or between friends who are very close to one another. And what you're saying is that you can stack the same kind of relationship components to build deep connections with our future selves. I think that's exactly right.
你与他们有了一种联系感，然后也许最终对他们有了一种责任感。所有这些事情，在某种程度上，一个接一个地堆叠在一起。当你拥有所有这些东西时，这就是你拥有父母与孩子之间，或者浪漫伴侣之间，或者非常亲密的朋友之间非常强大的纽带的时候。而你所说的是，你可以堆叠同样的关系组件来建立与我们未来自我的深层联系。我认为这完全正确。
And your right, the analogy can only go so far. Once had somebody ask me, you know, well, can you marry your future self? Well, you can't do that. The answer is no. The answer is no. But as an analogy, it's exactly right. And we can change the level of connection that we have to be boy, essentially deepening that connection. And I view a lot of this work in the space of current and future selves is doing something similar, trying to really dial up that connection that people have to their future selves.
而且你是对的，类比只能到此为止。曾经有人问我，你知道，好吧，你能和未来的自己结婚吗？好吧，你不能那样做。答案是不。答案是不。但作为一个类比，它是完全正确的。我们可以改变我们所拥有的联系程度，本质上是加深那种联系。我将这空间中的许多工作视为当前和未来自我，正在做类似的事情，试图真正调高人们与他们未来自我之间的联系。
We've seen how making our future selves seem less like strangers and more like friends can help us plan better. When we come back, how to make it easier for our current cells to sacrifice for the people will become in the future. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. UCLA psychologist Hal Hirschfield is the author of the book, Your Future Self, How to Make Tomorrow Better Today. He has studied the methods we can use to cultivate a closer, warmer relationship with our future cells.
我们已经看到，将未来的自己看作朋友而非陌生人，能帮助我们更好地规划未来。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何让现在的自己更容易为未来的自己做出牺牲。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。加州大学洛杉矶分校的心理学家哈尔·赫什菲尔德是《未来的你：如何让明天变得更好》一书的作者。他研究了如何与未来的自己建立更亲密、更温暖关系的方法。
How one of the challenges of seeing our future cells as a friend, a friend that we should care about, is that all the hard work only seems to go in one direction. Our future friends don't make sacrifices for us, but we need to make a ton of sacrifices for them. Now of course this is simply because time runs forwards, not backwards. We grow into our future cells. Our future cells don't grow into us. But one way to mitigate the sense that this is a one way relationship is to reduce the pain we feel when we make sacrifices in the present for our future cells. You say that we should pay attention to the
将未来的自己视为一个值得关心的朋友，其挑战之一在于所有的努力似乎都是单向的。未来的朋友不会为我们做出牺牲，但我们却需要为他们做出大量牺牲。当然，这仅仅是因为时间是向前流动的，而不是向后。我们成长为未来的自己，而未来的自己并不会成长为现在的我们。但缓解这种单向关系感的一种方法，是减轻我们在当下为未来的自己做出牺牲时所感受到的痛苦。你说我们应该注意……
language we use by breaking sacrifices into smaller units. Give me an example of how this works. So you're absolutely right. In some ways, this relationship, it's like a bad relationship where you're always sacrificing for your partner and they're doing nothing for you. So you're right. Part of the job here is to figure out how do we make those present day sacrifices feel psychologically easier to undertake.
我们所使用的语言，通过将牺牲拆解成更小的单位。能给我举个例子说明这是如何运作的吗？你说得完全正确。在某种程度上，这种关系就像一段糟糕的关系，你总是为伴侣牺牲，而他们却什么都不为你做。所以你是对的。这里的部分工作就是找出如何让这些当下的牺牲在心理上更容易承担。
And I think the framing of them matters here. So in one project that I conducted with Shilmo Benarzi and Steve Shoe, we worked with a FinTech company as a savings app, ACORNs, and everybody who signs up during this period of time that we were running this project are given the opportunity to sign up for an automatic savings account. Now, for some of them, we ask, you want to sign up for the savings account? It's 150 bucks a month that you can save.
我认为对它们的框架设定很重要。在我与什洛莫·贝纳齐和史蒂夫·舒共同进行的一项研究中，我们与一家名为ACORNs的金融科技储蓄应用公司合作。在项目期间注册的所有人都有机会开通自动储蓄账户。对于其中一些人，我们问：“你想开通储蓄账户吗？每月可以存150美元。”
It'll come out every month. You know, another group, we ask, if you want to save five bucks a day. Now, this is the same exact amount, right? Right, five bucks a day, time's 30 days, there's 150 bucks a month. Exactly, exactly. If anything, by the way, annually,
“这笔钱每个月都会扣除。”你知道，对于另一组人，我们问：“你想每天存5美元吗？”这完全是相同的金额，对吧？没错，每天5美元，乘以30天，就是每月150美元。完全正确，完全正确。顺便说一句，如果按年度计算，
because there's different days in a month, annually, it's five bucks a day, it's a little bit more. But what's interesting about this from my perspective is that it's the same thing,'s five bucks a day, it's a little bit more. But what's interesting about this from my perspective is that it's the same thing, but $5 a day, it just feels a little bit easier. It doesn't feel like such a big sacrifice. So I know that it can be for some people, but for a lot of people, it's relatively easy
因为每个月的天数不同，按年度算，每天5美元其实会多一点。但从我的角度来看，有趣的是，这本质上是一回事，但每天5美元感觉更容易接受。它感觉不像是一次巨大的牺牲。我知道对某些人来说可能还是有难度，但对很多人来说，
to think about something I'll give up that's five bucks a day. It's a lot harder to think about something that I spent $150 a month on and giving that up. It's like, there's only a few things that fall into that category. Now, what we found was that about seven percent of people sign up when it's $150 a month, but 30 percent sign up when it's $5 a day. Four times as many? Four times as many. I mean, these are big numbers.
考虑放弃每天5美元的东西相对容易。而考虑放弃每月150美元的东西就难多了。因为能归入这一类别的消费项目并不多。我们发现，当以每月150美元为单位时，约有7%的人注册；而当以每天5美元为单位时，有30%的人注册。是四倍之多？是四倍之多。我的意思是，这些数字非常惊人。
And we got to remember, these are folks who already are in a savings app, so they're already sort of warmly leads. You wouldn't expect 7% even. That's great. But the difference was almost surprising to us. That's a 4X difference there. Why is it that $5 a day feels so much more manageable to us than $150 a month? One possibility is that it's because we struggle to think about time and especially chunks
我们要记住，这些人已经是储蓄应用的用户了，所以他们已经是潜在的意向客户。你甚至不会预期有7%的转化率。这很棒。但这种差异对我们来说几乎是令人惊讶的。那是四倍的差距。为什么每天5美元比每月150美元让我们感觉更容易管理？一种可能性是我们难以系统性地思考时间，尤其是时间块。
of time in a systematic way. The researchers Neil Lewis Jr. and Daphna Oysterman once explored this possibility in a study that tried to get people to focus on retirement goals that were three decades into the future. They ask people to think about retirement, it's coming in about 11,000 days, or think about retirement, it's going to be in about 30 years, you have to get people relatively the same age to do this. Now, it's interesting. It's the same framing, but you know, days feel short and and years feel long. And what happened here is when the event in the future was framed in terms of days until the event, it felt like it was happening sooner. It felt like it was closer. Those days seemed to tick by faster compared to when it was framed as years in the future. And
研究人员尼尔·刘易斯和达芙娜·奥伊斯曼曾在一项研究中探讨过这种可能性，试图让人们关注三十年后的退休目标。他们让人们思考退休，是大约11000天后，或者思考退休，是大约30年后。你必须让年龄相仿的人来做这个实验。这很有趣。框架是一样的，但你知道，天数感觉很短，而年数感觉很长。结果是，当未来的事件以“距离事件还有多少天”来表述时，感觉它发生得更快，感觉更近。与以“未来多少年”来表述相比，那些日子似乎过得更快。而且
that had an impact on people's motivation. Folks who got that sort of day framing said that they would start planning for retirement. About four times sooner than the folks who got the year framing. Wow. So, I mean, of course, at a mathematical level, you know, 10,950 days is the same as 30 years. And you might actually think that the bigger number would dissuade people more, because that seems like a bigger number, it's further away.
这对人们的动力产生了影响。那些收到“天数”框架的人表示，他们会开始为退休做规划，比收到“年数”框架的人快四倍。哇。所以，我的意思是，当然，从数学层面来看，你知道，10950天和30年是一样的。你可能实际上认为更大的数字会劝退人们，因为它看起来是一个更大的数字，感觉更遥远。
But in some ways, people pay more attention to the days and the years than they do to the number of preceding the days and the years. I think that's exactly right. I have a very good sense of how long a day feels. It's pretty short relative to a year. And 30 years that feels like a lot. I mean, 10,950 days also feels like a lot, but it's a little more vivid. I can picture those days faster, and that brings that event closer to me, subjectively speaking.
但在某种程度上，人们对“天”和“年”的关注，超过了对天数和年数前面那个数字的关注。我认为这完全正确。我对一天有多长有很好的感知。相对于一年来说，它很短。而30年感觉很漫长。我的意思是，10950天也感觉很漫长，但它更生动。我可以更快地想象出那些日子，从主观上讲，这让那个事件离我更近了。
There's another neat trick that the economist Shlomo Benarzi and Richard Thaler have devised. They call it automatic escalation. The idea is that, let's say I'm saving at three or four percent of my paycheck right now, I will commit that my contribution level will automatically increase in the future. And not just in the future, but in conjunction with, say, raises that I'm going to get.
经济学家什洛莫·贝纳齐和理查德·塞勒还设计了另一个巧妙的技巧。他们称之为“自动升级”。这个想法是，假设我现在正按工资的3%或4%进行储蓄，我承诺我的缴存比例在未来会自动增加。而且不仅仅是在未来，而是与我未来获得的加薪挂钩。
The brilliance here is that if I say, okay, let's bump up from four to four and a half percent at the same time that I get a raise, it's not going to feel that painful to that future version of me. And also, there's something that's really smart about this because I'm committing some future guy. Right. It's his problem, not my problem. Exactly.
这里的精妙之处在于，如果我说，好吧，在我加薪的同时，将储蓄比例从4%提高到4.5%，这对未来的我来说并不会感到那么痛苦。而且，这其中还有非常聪明的一点，因为我是在为未来的那个家伙做承诺。没错。那是他的问题，不是我的问题。完全正确。
Yeah. I mean, and part of what I think is really interesting about this is that we are often not very mindful of what's going to happen in the future as we've been discussing, and in some ways this is harnessing the fact that we're not very mindful about what's happening in the future to actually pay more attention to our future self. It's kind of genius. Absolutely. The genius of this is it almost takes one of our, quote unquote, time-traveling mistakes
是的。我的意思是，我认为这其中非常有趣的一部分是，正如我们一直在讨论的那样，我们往往不太关注未来会发生什么。在某种程度上，这是利用了我们对未来缺乏关注这一事实，来真正地更多地关注未来的自己。这简直是天才之举。绝对是。这种天才之处在于，它几乎利用了我们所谓的“时间旅行错误”，
so you know, not really pay attention to our future selves, their interests, and rather than change it harness it to get people to do things that will in fact help those future selves by increasing savings contributions. Now, a stronger version of this kind of, you know, future contract is to add some accountability to the mix, to become accountable to someone else, to keep our commitments. I understand that a friend of yours has a clever way of keeping himself accountable for what he eats. What does he do?
你知道，就是不去真正关注未来的自己及其利益，而不是去改变它，而是利用它来促使人们做一些实际上能帮助那些未来自己的事情，即增加储蓄额。现在，这种“未来契约”的更强版本是增加一些问责制，即对他人负责，以信守我们的承诺。我听说你的一位朋友有一种巧妙的方法来监督自己的饮食。他是怎么做的？
One of my friends, I remember this really well because he's not one of those folks who takes pictures of his food. I'm sure everybody has those people in their lives and my friend Craig is like just not that guy. And one day I was at lunch with, and my friend Craig is just not that guy. And one day I was at lunch with him, and I noticed him taking pictures of his food, and I thought, what's going on here? By the way, it wasn't like a particularly beautiful meal. It was just like a sandwich from the work,
我的一位朋友，我记得很清楚，因为他不是那种会给食物拍照的人。我相信每个人的生活中都有这样的人，而我的朋友克雷格就不是那种人。有一天我和他一起吃午饭，我注意到他在给食物拍照，我想，这是怎么回事？顺便说一句，那并不是什么特别精美的餐点。那只是工作场所的一份三明治，
you know, the little cafe here. And he said, oh, you know, I'm working with this nutritionist. And she has me sending photos of everything that I'm eating. And one of the things that he had said to me is really funny, he felt like he didn't want to sort of mess up and eat something unhealthy because he didn't want to let down this person. By the way, she didn't even live in the US. It's not like she could hold any sweat. Probably wasn't even looking at the US. It's not like she could hold any sleep. I probably wasn't even looking at the pictures. Exactly, right?
你知道，就是这里的小咖啡馆。他说，哦，你知道，我正在和一位营养师合作。她让我发送我吃的所有东西的照片。他对我说的其中一件事真的很有趣，他觉得他不想搞砸，吃一些不健康的东西，因为他不想让这个人失望。顺便说一句，她甚至不住在美国。并不是说她能监督他。她可能甚至没在看照片。完全正确，对吧？
But I do remember that one day, I said, there's a bag of peanuts on your lap there. You know, he's like, oh, oh, oh, I forgot. I meant to put that. So some cheating might actually help us keep our resolutions. There's resupp in that front too. Exactly, exactly.
但我确实记得有一天，我说，你腿上有袋花生。你知道，他说，哦，哦，哦，我忘了。我本打算把它放……所以一些作弊行为实际上可能有助于我们坚持我们的决心。在这方面也有研究。完全正确，完全正确。
So there's another way of raising our commitment levels, and that is to take away the options that would tempt us from the path that we want to pursue. Tell me about the work of an entrepreneur who came up with an invention that involved a lockbox. It gave Krippendorf, he was a MIT grad student, and he lived right near a whole food. And every time he found himself having difficulty
所以还有另一种提高我们承诺水平的方法，那就是消除那些会诱惑我们偏离想要追求的道路的选择。跟我说说那位发明了带锁盒子的一位企业家的工作。那是克里彭多夫，他是麻省理工学院的研究生，他住的地方离全食超市很近。每次他发现自己在做习题集时遇到困难，
with a problem set, you know, he'd walk across the street and grab a snack, you know, of course, these aren't cheap. And so he's finding himself kind of hurting on two fronts, right, he's paying more money and he's snacking too much. And he's like, I've got to come up with a solution here. And he starts sort of talking to folks and he creates this little lock box that he puts in the kitchen. He calls it the kitchen safe. And it's basically a little box and it's got a digital timer with a lock on it. And it can go anywhere from a minute to 10 days days and he can throw his snacks in there and lock it up.
你知道，他就会穿过马路去买零食，你知道，当然，这些零食并不便宜。所以他发现自己在两个方面都受到了伤害，对吧，他花了更多的钱，而且零食吃得太多了。他想，我必须想出一个解决方案。于是他开始和人们交谈，并创造了这个放在厨房里的小锁盒。他称之为“厨房保险箱”。它基本上是一个小盒子，上面有一个带锁的数字计时器。它可以设置从一分钟到十天的时间，他可以把零食扔进去并锁起来。
Well, some of his friends start getting ahold of this and he likes it and he ends up going on Shark Tank and wins a whole bunch of money and leaves his high paying post-MIT business MIT Business School job to really go full on in this entrepreneurial endeavor. But what was so interesting about this is that he finds from the users of this kitchen safe that they're using it for all sorts of things. They're locking away not just snacks and food, but drugs and alcohol and prescription medication that you can only take at a certain number of hours and so on and so on. And so he changes the name to the case safe.
好吧，他的一些朋友开始接触这个东西，他们很喜欢，他最终上了《创智赢家》节目，赢了一大笔钱，并离开了他在麻省理工学院商学院的高薪职位，全身心地投入到这项创业事业中。但最有趣的是，他从这个厨房保险箱的用户那里发现，他们用它来做各种各样的事情。他们锁住的不仅仅是零食和食物，还有毒品、酒精和处方药，这些药只能在特定的时间服用等等。所以他把名字改成了“案例保险箱”。
What's great about this is that he's essentially creating a device that makes it easy for us to commit to a certain course of action by automatically taking away the temptation, by taking away the thing that we are worried we are going to mess up on. There's one final step in hardening our commitments and that is to add consequences for violating our resolutions. And one way to do that is to pit consequences for violating our resolutions. And one way to do that is to pit different drives in the mind against each other, as we've discussed earlier. You cite one technique that pits our desire to give into temptations against our desire to avoid losing things. It's called burn or burn.
最棒的是，他本质上创造了一种设备，通过自动消除诱惑，消除我们担心会搞砸的事情，使我们更容易承诺采取某种行动。在巩固我们的承诺方面还有最后一步，那就是增加违反决心的后果。一种方法是让头脑中不同的驱动力相互对抗，正如我们之前讨论的那样。你引用了一种技巧，它将我们屈服于诱惑的欲望与我们避免失去东西的欲望对立起来。它被称为“烧掉或烧掉”。
How does it work out? Yeah, Nieriel has this great idea, which is that he knows he wants to burn calories every day, but he also knows that he may be tempted to not do it. On his dresser, he has a $100 bill, and he has a lighter, and he's tacked that bill up to a quirk board, and he calls it the burner burn technique. And the idea is that if he doesn't burn calories in some way that day, he's got a burn, the $100 bill. And it's really an interesting strategy because you're injecting a sort of punishment for a future version of yourself if you mess up something.
它是如何运作的？是的，尼里尔有一个很棒的想法，他知道他每天都想消耗卡路里，但他也知道他可能会受到诱惑而不去做。在他的梳妆台上，有一张100美元的钞票，他有一个打火机，他把那张钞票钉在软木板上，他称之为“烧掉或烧掉”技巧。这个想法是，如果他那天没有以某种方式消耗卡路里，他就得烧掉那100美元。这是一个非常有趣的策略，因为如果你搞砸了某件事，你就是在为未来的自己注入一种惩罚。
So it can kind of help create a sense of guardrails. I don't want to deviate from my plan because if I do, I know I'm going to get punished. Now, in that particular case, it requires an extra dose of self-control because now I have to actually follow through with it. That can be hard to do. Hmm.
所以这可以在某种程度上帮助建立一种护栏感。我不想偏离我的计划，因为如果我这样做，我知道我会受到惩罚。现在，在这种特殊情况下，它需要额外的自控力，因为现在我必须真正执行它。这可能很难做到。嗯。
Hmm. You know, in an early episode of Hidden Brain Hal, I was trying to get a colleague of mine to quit smoking. And so I asked him to make a commitment to quit and added a very painful punishment, which is if he started smoking again, he would have to donate money to an organization he detested. And this idea, of course, came from the platform stick.com. It's spelled STICKK.com, which helps people stay bound to their commitments. What is the data show about the effectiveness of programs like stick?
嗯。你知道，在《隐藏的大脑》早期的一集中，哈尔，我曾试图让我的一位同事戒烟。所以我让他做出戒烟的承诺，并增加了一个非常痛苦的惩罚，那就是如果他再次开始吸烟，他就必须向一个他厌恶的组织捐款。这个想法当然来自平台stick.com。拼写是STICKK.com，它帮助人们坚守承诺。数据对像stick这样的项目的有效性有什么显示？
Yeah, so recent research led by Craig Brimhall has found that people who sign up with a punishment attach and you don't have to add a punishment, but if you do, the people who add in the punishment are four times as likely to follow through with their commitments compared to the people who don't add that punishment in. That's remarkable. Yeah, I mean, it is remarkable and it makes sense because I really don't want to lose out
是的，由克雷格·布林霍尔领导的最新研究发现，那些注册时附加了惩罚的人——你不必增加惩罚，但如果你这样做——那些增加惩罚的人，坚持承诺的可能性是那些没有增加惩罚的人的四倍。这太了不起了。是的，我的意思是，这确实了不起，而且很有道理，因为我真的不想失去东西，
and I don't want to suffer the punishment, especially when I know that the person who deserves the blame is essentially me. So we've talked at length today, Hal, about ways in which we can avoid prioritizing our present selves over our future selves. But some of us can also tip over in the other direction and start to prioritize our future cells over our present cells exclusively. And of course that can mean that we lose out on enjoyable things in the here and now.
我也不想遭受惩罚，尤其是当我意识到应该受到责备的人本质上是我自己的时候。所以，哈尔，我们今天详细讨论了我们可以避免优先考虑现在的自己而不是未来的自己的方法。但我们中的一些人也可能走向另一个极端，开始完全优先考虑未来的自己而不是现在的自己。当然，这意味着我们可能会失去当下享受事物的机会。
Can you talk about that risk, Hal? Sure. So, you know, so much of my own career has been focused on my opi-a or being tunnel focused on the present so that we ignore the future. But there's this other sort of type of bias that we have that's called hyper opia where we're almost too focused on the future and end up ignoring the present. Here's a great example of it. It comes from work by Suzanne Shou. If you've ever had a gift certificate to a restaurant, and you said, okay, yeah, I'm
你能谈谈那个风险吗，哈尔？当然。所以，你知道，我自己的职业生涯中有很大一部分专注于我的“近视”，或者说对当下过于关注，以至于我们忽略了未来。但我们还有另一种偏见，叫做“远视”，即我们对未来过于关注，最终忽略了当下。这里有一个很好的例子。它来自苏珊·舒的研究。如果你曾经有一张餐厅的礼券，你说，好吧，是的，我
going to wait for the perfect time to use that gift certificate. And then the restaurant closes. In some ways, this is hyper-optic. You have been so focused on doing something right in the future that you forget that it may make more sense to just do that thing now, here's the irony here. This is another mistake where even though we think we're doing something for the future, waiting for the perfect moment, we end up making life worse for our future selves because now they haven't had that experience. We've also made life worse for our present selves because we haven't had that experience.
要等待完美的时机来使用那张礼券。然后餐厅倒闭了。在某种程度上，这就是“远视”。你太专注于在未来做正确的事情，以至于你忘记了现在就做那件事可能更有意义。这里的讽刺之处在于，这是另一个错误，即使我们认为我们在为未来做某事，等待完美的时刻，我们最终却让未来的自己生活得更糟，因为现在他们没有获得那种体验。我们也让现在的自己生活得更糟，因为我们没有获得那种体验。
You know, one idea that follows from this hell is that living a successful and happy life involves seeing the big picture, not just prioritizing the needs of the present self and not just prioritizing the needs of the future self. You call this taking a bird's eye view of time. And I feel like we're almost in the realm of philosophy now, not just psychology. But can you tell me what you mean by that? And whether you are able to successfully apply that idea in your own life. So, Cassie McGillner Holmes, Jennifer Akron, I have been theorizing and thinking about this for years now. And the idea here is that we are often confronted with these moments where we say,
你知道，哈尔，由此产生的一个想法是，过上成功和幸福的生活涉及看到大局，而不仅仅是优先考虑现在自己的需求，也不仅仅是优先考虑未来自己的需求。你称之为“鸟瞰时间”。我觉得我们现在几乎处于哲学的领域，而不仅仅是心理学。但你能告诉我你是什么意思吗？以及你是否能够成功地在你自己的生活中应用这个想法。所以，卡西·麦吉尔纳·霍姆斯，詹妮弗·阿克伦，我多年来一直在理论化和思考这个问题。这里的想法是，我们经常面临这些时刻，我们说，
should I do this thing or not? Should I spend or should I save? We force ourselves to ask these sort of weather questions, whether I should do something or not. Our suspicion is that the birds I view of time changes that weather frame into a wind frame so that we can start thinking when should I do something and when should I not do something? When does that vacation make sense and when does it make sense to to save? In my own life I've applied this sort of thinking not just to how I spend and save, but also how I allocate time. More and more lately, especially with kids who are young, I've been thinking about, you know, when it makes sense to travel for work or not, and you know, when it makes sense to be fully present at home and when it doesn't, because ultimately, when
我应该做这件事吗？我应该消费还是应该储蓄？我们强迫自己问这些“是否”的问题，是否应该做某事。我们的怀疑是，时间的鸟瞰视角将那种“是否”的框架改变为“何时”的框架，这样我们就可以开始思考我应该在什么时候做某事，什么时候不应该做某事？那个假期什么时候有意义，什么时候储蓄才有意义？在我自己的生活中，我不仅将这种思维应用于我如何消费和储蓄，还应用于我如何分配时间。最近越来越多，尤其是有了年幼的孩子，我一直在思考，你知道，什么时候去出差有意义，什么时候没有，你知道，什么时候在家里全身心投入有意义，什么时候没有，因为最终，当
I sort of step back and I look down at my life and the way I imagine I will look down on it much later on, I think I'm going to want to be satisfied with how I've sent my time and not regret it. HAL Hirschfield is a psychologist at the Anderson School of Management at UCLA. He is the author of Your Future Self, How to Make Tomorrow Better Today. HAL, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarelle,
我退后一步，俯瞰我的生活，以及我想象很久以后我会如何看待它时，我想我会希望对自己度过时间的方式感到满意，而不是后悔。哈尔·赫什菲尔德是加州大学洛杉矶分校安德森管理学院的心理学家。他是《未来的你：如何让明天变得更好》的作者。哈尔，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、
Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Stacey Bond. Stacey works on the editorial team at Apple Podcasts and she's been an excellent partner as we've launched our new podcast subscription Hidden Brain Plus. Stacey has great curatorial instincts and is really committed to making sure that podcast listeners are exposed to great shows. She's been a big help in brainstorming ways to bring hidden brain plus to larger audiences
瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是斯泰西·邦德。斯泰西在苹果播客的编辑团队工作，在我们推出新的播客订阅《隐藏的大脑 Plus》时，她一直是一位出色的合作伙伴。斯泰西有很棒的策展直觉，并且非常致力于确保播客听众能接触到精彩的节目。她在集思广益，将《隐藏的大脑 Plus》带给更广泛的受众方面提供了很大的帮助，
and we're truly grateful for her creativity and attention to detail. Thank you Stacey. If you haven't yet tried out hidden brain plus we hope you'll give it a try. In our most recent episode, we explore how to navigate sensitive and difficult conversations. I need somebody to get it, I need somebody to understand, and to walk alongside me through some hard stuff, I think is really at the heart of so many difficult conversations in our lives. You can find Hidden Brain Plus in the Apple Podcast tab or at apple.co slash Hidden Brain.
我们真心感谢她的创造力和对细节的关注。谢谢你，斯泰西。如果你还没有尝试过《隐藏的大脑 Plus》，我们希望你能试一试。在我们最近的一集中，我们探讨了如何处理敏感和困难的对话。“我需要有人理解，我需要有人明白，并陪伴我度过一些困难的事情，我认为这确实是我们生活中许多困难对话的核心。”你可以在苹果播客标签页或 apple.co/HiddenBrain 找到《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。
Next week in our YouTube.io series, we explore how to master the art of slowing down and savoring our lives. I'm Shankar Vedanthantham. See you soon. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周在我们的 YouTube.io 系列节目中，我们将探讨如何掌握放慢节奏和品味生活的艺术。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。